if let's say you disagreed with me you'd
say why and uh if it made sense we'd
like air our differences publicly on on
the substance of it like what happens
when Tony Sachi does this is a sense
you're absolutely right just sends a
signal to all the other scientists in
biomedicine that if you step out of line
you know if attorney says I am the
science you know if you disagree with me
you're disagreeing with science itself
if you step out of line your career is
at stake you don't you don't want every
chronic idea but this was not a crank
idea these were prominent people in
respected institutions stay saying look
this is this policy is wrong
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
welcome everybody to a special
conversation with someone I've admired
for a very long time both for his
intellect uh and his uh perspicacity and
all the things that he does but but
Evermore so since he's taken such a
courageous stand in our public discourse
around the covid-19 pandemic creating uh
co-authoring the 2020 Great Barrington
declaration doing many many other uh
prescient things that are now only now
being recognized by the wider audience
we'll get into that and some of the
controversy that is still swirling
around but uh but this is a Dr J
bhattacharya who is a professor of
medicine economics and health research
policy at Stanford University and the
director of Stanford's Center for
demography and economics of health and
aging you really couldn't design better
you know Jay if if they had like a lab
where they could design things you know
for gain of function purposes I mean I
really feel like you're one of the you
know kind of um well for lack of a
better word of redundancy most unique I
hate that phrase but but it really
applies here you've got this incredible
blend of in raw intellectual horsepower
um you know just ability to ignite but
but be do so with Grace with humility
um and with uh with many great qualities
so it was an honor to meet you finally
uh we were together about a month ago in
in Italy and we'll talk a little bit
about some of the side trips we got to
take but uh Dr J balachera thank you for
joining me on the end to the impossible
podcast Ryan thank you for that very
kind introduction um I have to say like
with most of my career I wondered what
the heck I was doing because I didn't
know what the particular combination of
things I was interested in would really
apply to until the pandemic like that
then it sort of became a little more
clear to me uh maybe you know to to
cause some some uh some uproar in my
life but uh thank you for that yeah and
I I always think you know the rarest of
all the human qualities is to is to be
courageous and especially so and so much
is at risk and and to do so with no
expectation going in and no remuneration
thereof and in fact probably quite
potentially ruin us for for for people
so to take on the courage that you did
and I want to get into uh because I am
you know a practicing Jew as you know
and you're a practicing Christian I
wonder you know if our world views you
know which are different theologically
but not uh in terms of our of our
practice I think
um do you think your your faith played a
role you know from the from the outset
in the mission that you undertook and
and we're not you know my audience is
not you know so Keen to to be we're not
going to proselytize don't worry out
there in the into the Empire you know I
won't do that but but the point being uh
do you think it guided you do you think
uh that it sustained you during the the
controversy that we're going to speak
about I mean I I take my faith seriously
as you know Brian I know you do too um
and I found common cause with people
basically of no matter what religion who
take their faith seriously um and I
can't say like in terms of the
scientific work it didn't it didn't say
you know find some result or this with
this or that result that's I mean
science is science and you apply the
standards of science to it I think
um and I I try to do that but in terms
of
I mean I felt like I've had to speak out
and and my faith one of the main core
components for me is this this desire to
speak for the poor to to to to work if I
can to make the lives of the poor better
um and especially in how policy it's a
it's a place where uh where you know
people's fundamental values uh about
about what what what happens in their
life their their health their well-being
um how that's distributed in society
that it's those are like absolutely
fundamental Topics in our policy and for
me it's my faith is is part of that I
mean it's part of like why I care about
this topic so much because I I think
that what's happened during the pandemic
the pandemic policy you followed has
been absolutely devastating to the lives
of the poor to children and vulnerable
people and that's that is definitely has
driven me yeah and looking looking at
the
um at the you know kind of uh mentality
of of our fellow citizens and how they
react to uh not just the pandemic but
the lockdown I think was the significant
contribution of course your medical
doctor you have unique insight into the
most vulnerable population but but it
was really you know people call it well
because of kovid we had X Y or Z but
really it was the effects of the
pandemic lockdown not the pandemic
itself that really Drew your most of
your attention and and actually where I
think you made tremendous contributions
which may only be recognized you know
decades from now
um and in the prevention of similar
mistakes but uh but I you know you don't
have to react to that but but I did want
to you know kind of when I met you and
we spent some time together you know I
was reminded of a uh of another of
another profit with the name uh starting
with the name j the letter J and that's
uh Jeremiah
um and and I wonder how do you reconcile
you know some of of his famous quotes I
mean of course there's a famous one that
people like to bring out from abortion
debates which we're not going to get
into here AJ we can get into abortion
gun control
however many controversial topics
let's let's uh let's let's play it a
little say but but of course famous
quote before I formed you in the womb I
knew you before you were born I set you
apart
um does any uh the biblical you know
versus not again I don't talk about
abortion per se but but um does it give
to you as it does to me perhaps uh a
notion that every life is sacred even
our enemies even those that that hate us
and do vile things to us
um that every life is sacred and again
we're not talking about abortion right
now I mean we should talk about that
some other time but but does that guide
you as a doctor uh as a as you know a
theologically inclined person or can you
divorce you know being your your
scientific attributes from your
religious attributes well I think um I
mean I love that quote uh not not
particularly because it has a
controversial linked to abortion but
because it gives this sense that we are
each of us created with a purpose
um that we have are given our gifts for
a reason they're not just for ourselves
um and I think that that that that that
I love that because that that idea that
uh we're all made in God's image that
means I have to treat you like you're
made in God's image with respect and
with dignity
um and and help you with your purpose I
mean I love that I love that idea and it
has it has animated my work uh and
animated how I try to treat each other
it's been really difficult during
pandemic I've I've made a lot of enemies
unfortunately uh not not intentionally
but just by my ideas
um and I've had to work very hard to
unders to remember that even they
um are made in God's image or people
that are worthy of respect of worthy of
dignity and to work to forgive them even
if they've harmed me
um I mean those are like personal
attributes uh I think in science we have
an obligation to speak what we see as
the truth uh you know based on our work
to the best of our abilities to correct
ourselves when we get it wrong
um and to and to and to treat each other
with dignity and respect even if we
disagree that that quote from Jeremiah I
think is I love that because I think it
underlies a lot of that kind of ethic
and I've tried to live that as best I
can and his other quote uh of course
that I love to you know Trot out on
faculty meetings is uh the heart is
deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked who can know it so uh
you know he was famous for these
Jeremiahs where we get the name Jeremiah
which is kind of a Clarion call a
warning
um you know I've written a little bit
about that and completely uh
uncourageous stance compared to you just
with regards to you there's this
Alexander Sol's an interesting question
it's probably my very favorite thing uh
favorite quote is this I think you gave
it a speech at Harvard uh you know so
since of course the the the
Soviet dissident who wrote the gulag
archipelago he said look the line
between good and evil cuts through every
human heart there is no purely good and
purely evil people were all in some some
sense a mix and we're trying to like get
along with each other in that sense with
that if we understand that then
it's much easier to treat other people
with with respect if we can I mean it's
hard sometimes when people are attacking
you
um but uh you have to I've tried to
remember that yeah hey friends just a
quick request while you're enjoying this
video to leave a thumbs up my thumb's a
little bit preoccupied with all Carl
Sagan over here but I hope yours is free
enough to leave a like it really helps
me with the algorithm and for extra
credit homework assignment leave a
comment down below what you're enjoying
about this video now back to the show
especially as we'll get to you know
people that portray themselves as as you
know devout Christians and and then come
down with profoundly
um uh not not only on Christian but
perhaps undignified ways of Behaving I
want to Pivot from you know our
theological uh out you know discussion
at the outset here too uh a notion of
you know that which came to sort of
replace it we were of course replete
with this in in Renaissance Italy
um and and that's science and and you
know of course science you know the
people that write history The Victors
right so they got to call themselves The
Enlightenment they got to call
themselves The Renaissance they got to
call the previous ages the Dark Ages uh
so you know it's it's kind of um I've
heard that the that the uh English as in
UK textbooks don't mention the
Revolutionary War to in great detail but
but that's uh besides the point
um is there such a thing as you know
science uh uh is there such a thing as
the scientific method uh are these just
sort of like um you know hyperlinks that
we keep in our mind but we don't really
know what they mean do you think there
is some something that can reasonably
called be called the science or science
or even the scientific method quote
unquote
well I think I do think there's a
scientific method but I think that the
term that we normally think of as the
science is really it's just like a it's
if you if you take it very broadly it's
it's an attempt for humans to try to
understand how the material world Works
how the physical world Works to try to
think of explanations for it
um and uh the um the difference between
I think pre-enlightenment signings which
was science in its in in reality still
science and post Enlightenment science
is an emphasis on material causes for
material outcomes
um you don't make reference to God when
you say you know why did this happen in
scientific discussion post-enlightenment
I think that's been quite productive
actually
um I think it's it's disciplined people
to try to look to see what can be told
what can be learned just by looking at
Material material inputs
um material meaning just a very broadly
material like you know I mean you know
what's more about the way the universe
works than I do Brian's I'm not going to
try to get into that but I think um I
think the the idea that we can learn
about the way the world where works from
um from just from it from experimenting
with it with our with our intellects
um that's broadly been true forever even
before the enlightenment but but the set
of explanations that we're allowing
ourselves is limited to the material
explanations that's been quite
productive I think
um in our advance and knowledge about
the way the universe the material
Universe Works that doesn't mean there
isn't a Telos there doesn't mean that
there isn't some some purpose Beyond it
uh and I think in our everyday lives uh
it's a mix of our material knowledge you
know the fact that I know that if I hit
a hammer to a window it'll break that
doesn't mean I should hit a hammer to
the window I mean that's a very
different those are two different
questions there's a there's a there's a
scientific fact that hitting cameras to
Windows breaks the window and then
there's the the question of whether it's
the right or right thing to do to break
this window might be right if I'm you
know trapped in a car and it's and it's
burning I need to get out it might be
very wrong if I'm trying to like you
know break into somebody's house to
steal from them right right so I think
this very it's the the Telos is is
really quite important for how we live
but for science especially Enlightenment
Science Focus on the material cause has
been really really a good good thing I
think yeah when we look back you know
before we turn to slides that you're
going to show from a presentation that
you have uh when we look back in the
pandemic I first became aware of
covid-19 in early January 2020 and I was
at a Shabbat dinner on a Friday night
with a friend who listens to the podcast
and he's not you know he's like a social
psychologist you can think of as a
sports psychologist he helps me get into
you know fighting shape from my MMA
battle no he doesn't do that but but uh
he's a brilliant you know kind of a
social scientist and you know he was
just saying what are you up to this year
you know what are you looking forward to
that's I'm supposed to go to China to
Tibet to look at this cosmology project
that they've asked me to kind of consult
on and it's kind of a maybe a rival to
my project but but it'll be kind of
interesting to get complimentary data
from another group that has different
expertise and I'm excited about I've
never been to China
um certainly not to Tibet you might want
to hold off you know what are you think
going I said you know March April and
and he said you I want to reconsider
that did you hear about you know they've
got this disease yeah I'd heard about it
but uh he's like you know they just
built this Hospital in eight days that
doubles as a prison they can weld people
into it keep people out that's kind of
interesting uh but you know maybe push
it off to April July you know needless
to say I never went right I'm still uh
China still does not appear in my
passport uh Russia does but China
doesn't anyway the the point being uh
that my friend who's not a member of the
NSA CIA FBI DARPA uh you know the the
any of the multi-letter agencies he knew
about this you know so like a couple of
Jewish yentas you know at a dinner right
we knew about it in January
um by that time there could have been
you know many many more uh precautions
uh preventative measures put in place uh
maybe even a month earlier and and as an
epidemiologically trained individual you
know better than I how these things can
spread is there anything in retrospect
in hindsight before we get to the actual
uh incredible story what you have have
related and experience which which I I'm
just I begged you to share it with my
audience and so we will before we get
there could it have been avoided is
there any point you know in the multiple
branching Forks of the garden of forking
paths history could we have debate it to
minimis like a just a sniffle or was it
inevitable from the time it was either
created or released or or naturally you
know spread from from zoonotic Origins
could it have been prevented by any
technology any scientific or
technological Insight that Humanity as a
whole or the US in particular could have
applied
I don't I don't think so I think
unfortunately it was it was baked in the
cake I don't know if his natural origin
or zoonotic uh or even if it was a lab
leak in either case the dates of it
probably are in the fall of 2019. and
the evidence of that is that there are
antibody studies from uh from stored
blood in blood banks in places like
Italy Angola from September 2019 where
it shows up positive
now there's some dispute over whether
those are false positives but I think
it's really hard to just to like look at
this body of evidence say it's all false
positive I think sometime in Fall 2019
this this disease was already spreading
um throughout the world it was already
outside of China it's a highly
infectious disease it was too late even
by then it had we known about it to stop
it I do think that the actions of the
Chinese government uh worked to suppress
knowledge of it uh especially in
December that became clear you had some
heroic doctors in China speaking up and
they paid the price for it
um uh but uh but by certainly by January
2019 2020 uh when China had really
started their Draconian lockdown just as
you said it was far too late because it
wasn't just in China it already spread
outside the world you saw in um late
January 2019 the first case is the U.S
even before that there were cases in
Italy in Iran
um uh the the disease all was seeded
very widely especially in the northern
hemisphere early on
uh in by early on I mean January 2020 uh
shutting down travel was too late uh it
was you know I think people thought of
this as like the 2003 SARS one epidemic
where that it really did sort of Peter
itself out but that doesn't spread as
easily that virus didn't spread as
easily as this virus does this one seems
to spread by aerosols it you breathe in
the same you know I breathe in one room
and then you come back into that you
come back into that room an hour later
you might still get my covet
um that's that wasn't true I don't think
it was much harder to spread SARS one
um I don't think there was any mechanism
by which we could have avoided the
pandemic uh short of if it was a lab
League not doing those kinds of
exercises that led to the lab League
yeah and of course that has to be you
know at least the consideration and any
future research or you know kind of
precautions put into place uh in in the
future to prevent this from ever
happening again do you think that they
uh that the American public would would
tolerate another round of lockdown let's
say covid 23 God forbid uh comes around
covet 27 I don't care which in the
future have we been so scarred or have
we been chasing or do you think it would
just immediately happen again just as it
did in 2020 and Beyond I mean I was
stunned that the lockdowns were accepted
in 2020. I thought they would be much
broader push back against it what I
didn't anticipate was how important fear
was in the minds of people and driving
the behavior in minds of people in 2020.
you look back to March of 2020 it was a
time of great panic and fear in the
scientific Community not just not just
in in the public and in fact uh
governments used propaganda to to
actually induce fear it made it very
difficult to do uh any kind of
reasonable scientific minded thinking
about what the right policy ought to be
um so the answer to your question I
think is if there is another virus that
spreads around and
official dumb panics around it like they
did during covid I'm afraid that would a
lockdown would come back even if it
wasn't particularly useful for stopping
the spread of that virus that
hypothetical new virus um my one of my
goals in the post-pandemic time is to
try to reform Public Health Systems so
that they don't knee-jerk react with
fear to the the to a threat but instead
try to develop evidence very quickly and
assess what the right response ought to
be uh in a cool mind as opposed to
panicking themselves and then spreading
that Panic to the population at large
right we like to think of ourselves as
scientist that's dispassionate as
following the evidence and of course you
know I I have given talks or speak about
political comma scientists
um but um but you know to push back with
respect
um you know it's often said that well
America has one of the lowest numbers of
of scientists in in public policy and
you look at the kind of you know crazed
reaction and an illegitimate you know
kind of hyperbole surrounding everything
not not just of our uncovered reaction
so wouldn't it be better if uh our
government were you know a scientocracy
or something like that where you had the
the most brilliant yeah and you and I
would be the leaders of it I mean it's
gonna be great Jay oh God forbid
definitely
Brian and Jay rule the universe uh but
no we have brilliant colleagues you know
these are I know 14 Nobel Prize winners
uh you know some on your campus up there
and and yeah why not just have these
brilliant Geniuses
um um the men and women of science uh
not only advising you know President
Biden I mean what does he he doesn't
know much about science I don't think
um so why not have the have an elevated
role for scientists in the government to
enact policies that are fact-tested
replicable uh they are peer-reviewed uh
all these things why not what's wrong
with that Jay well I'm not against
having more scientists advise
governments um what I found and I've had
a lot of opportunities during pandemic
to interact with politicians of some of
who actually are quite Adept at
following scientific arguments and
others who just it's hopeless
um I I think I don't think there's
anything wrong with that the question is
what's their proper role right so
scientists can can tell you how to break
a window but the scientists can't tell
you whether you should break a window
um those that involves trade-offs values
that people fundamentally have so
um you ask uh about about like how
scientists performed official scientists
performed
um during the pandemic I have to say
rather poorly
um I mean I think uh that that there's
two things that happen one is that they
in the midst of panic that was that
scientists themselves that promote
Health people in themselves induced
um they were very bad at reading
evidence and then second they took on
themselves this role that that we are
really unsuited for we're not we're not
King we're not philosopher Kings Brian
uh I mean we have our our blind sights
and we we have our values which may may
differ with other people's values it's
essentially possible the way that's
mediated in society in a Democratic
Society is through politics
unfortunately there's no other way
really I mean there's no there's no
benevolent philosopher king that can
decide this is the right thing to do you
have to have uh the possibility that
people people of different values
um discussing with each other sometimes
sometimes you know in in unpleasant ways
um but that process results in at least
some kind of compromise
um scientists what we can do is we can
say well if you do a b is likely to
happen
and then everyone can just can argue
with each other whether B is a good
thing or a bad thing we are not very
good at that
so
um to go back to our uh you know kind of
origin of our relationship in person uh
we were treated to a presentation of
basically you know a hellscape a life
basically of of nightmarish uh
proportions that I I really you know I
was almost brought to to tears I told my
wife about this and um and the shameful
treatment that you suffered um both at
the hands of local officials the media
the Press uh and then you know your
institution at Stanford which I called
home for a very brief period of time and
then the national government and I
wonder if we could uh you know share
some of their Recollections I know it's
painful but but I think the um the world
needs to to know the story and and I
want to play as you know even though
it'll be a tiny role some some component
and some role in in Sharing what you've
experienced with the world as
um both a fascinating you know in the
same way uh uh a horror movie is To Me
you're gratified to not be in the movie
if you're watching this
um uh what Jay went through I wouldn't
wish on my worst enemies and and I can
only I can't really sympathize or
empathize with it but I can just say
um you know how much it moved me so I
wonder if you could share those those uh
that presentation now Jay I would I'd be
delighted um although it is it is having
lived through it wasn't the most fun
thing but uh but I think it's cathartic
to just talk about it okay
uh so uh I'm gonna tell two there's two
parts to my story uh uh and it it starts
basically in um in March 2020.
um I I had been following covet of
course before uh before the pandemic uh
before before March 2020 because just
like you I've seen those reports out of
China and so on
um I I'd also had been I've done work on
infectious disease epidemiology
infectious policy for two decades before
this one of my very first papers were on
HIV policy for instance
um and uh you know published uh
peer-reviewed literature on on this and
and I've been paying attention in during
the H1N1 pandemic when what happened was
that very early on in 2009 during that
pandemic the World Health Organization
put out a report saying that there was
going to be a three four five percent
mortality from swine flu from H1N1
um and what happened after that was
really amazing to me like if there were
a whole bunch of studies in the
population at Large
of of
uh antibody stage one and one specific
antibodies so that you could measure how
many people actually had had H1N1 and
then what was the uh what was the what
was the the uh uh what was the actual
rate the prevalence of the disease as
opposed to like you know if you just
rely on people showing up in the
hospital you're only seeing the tip of
the iceberg it turns out right um those
zero problem studies showed a very large
number of people in the population in
during H1N1 having antibodies meaning
that a lot of people that had gotten
H1N1 and then recovered from it never
went to the hospital and so those early
death rate estimates three four five
percent turned out to be a hundred times
higher than was actually turned out to
be true eventually it took a year or
more about but if that's but that's
partly why the H1N1 pandemic sort of
fizzled out people learned that it was
much less deadly than they thought that
it had spread much more widely than they
realized uh based on these Sarah
prevalent studies so in March as a blood
sample test right yeah a blood test so
uh you're speaking to a lot of
cosmologists so you know yeah so zero
travel zero means blood uh and uh
prevalence means how frequent is it um
so you do a population sample of of
blood usually it's just a little finger
prick or sometimes a blood of a more a
bigger blood draw and then there are
standard tests to see if you have
antibody that's specific that
specifically reacts to H1N1 and not to
other viruses or other pathogens
um so if you have this path this
antibody that means you've been exposed
and recovered
um there's sometimes disputes over
whether those antibodies actually
protect you against getting disease
again but there's no dispute that having
the antibody means you are exposed
and you and you must have recovered
because you're not dead
um anyway so that that was that was the
debate during H1N1 and when um when
covet hit I had the thought that look
this is this is a very highly infectious
respiratory virus maybe this happened
again this is happening again um the
world's Health Organization this is on
the screen you can see the World Health
Organization put out a report in March
of 2020 saying the death rate's 3.4
percent
well uh I mean my first thought reaction
to that was this is this can't be right
they don't know this number
they don't know this number because they
don't know how many people actually have
been exposed they haven't run the serial
prevalent studies that would have
allowed them to actually say what the
death rate actually was
um and so uh I you know I spent my
entire career Brian writing
peer-reviewed papers I have uh never
been on TV I think I was I mean TV one
time in the past I can't remember it was
it was like a nothing thing
um uh in 2000 like in the 2000s
um and and I've never written an op-ed I
all of my work and all my focus has been
on writing papers right I saw this and I
thought to myself I have to say I have
to say something and so I wrote an op-ed
uh you can see that on the screen uh in
March 24th 2020 uh we all that changed
my life I mean it utterly was was
shocking to me how much it changed my
life but it did
um the uh the op-ed if you read it uh
basically said try to try to like figure
out what the death rate might be based
on the very limited evidence we have
and I came to the conclusion that if
they're very wide range of numbers were
possible too wider range it could have
been very very low death rate like H1N1
was or could have been as high as the
World Health Organization was saying it
was impossible to know until you
actually ran a study a Serial problem
study to measure what fraction of the
population had the virus um so that was
the conclusion of this of this op-ed
that was published in the Wall Street
Journal in March 20. how could you know
just a naive I mean how could you know
that it was I mean it could also be too
low by orders of magnitude if we have no
other things to base it on if it's truly
novel you know genotype in in the
history of planet Earth I mean couldn't
have also been too low um I mean how did
you know to be confident before there
were these studies in other words I mean
uh that that it you know couldn't be
equally underestimating and it could be
much worse I mean so there's two parts
to this just this is way easier than
cosmology so it's very simple so it's a
new there's a numerator the number of
deaths and the denominator number of
infected people right and the number of
deaths you have to wait a couple of
weeks because it takes you a couple
weeks action and deaths at the time
um uh the the question was uh that my
focus was on the denominator how many
people were infected yeah and that had
to have been an underestimate that could
only really be an underestimate because
we were estimating that based on how
many people showed up at the hospital
right or showed up with with positive
tests there weren't enough tests back
then yeah um the PCR test had just been
developed uh and they weren't and you
know remember there was a shortage of
that right and so we were I think we
were very clearly underestimating the
denominator uh it's true Brian you could
have we could also have been
underestimating the numerator there
might have been people that died from
covid that that we didn't catch
I think it's a big problem for instance
in poor countries where the Healthcare
systems were poor
um uh but in uh in the United States
basically everyone with a respiratory
infection severe enough to get into the
hospital was being tested for covet at
the time yeah it seemed unlikely to me
that the numerator was was uh was vastly
underestimated I know there's some
people who thought that but I think they
were it was unlikely
um but my focus wasn't on the numerator
uh even if the numerator were doubled it
doesn't really change the fact about the
denominator that you can measure
independently using these zero prevalent
studies that make sense yeah
um anyways I wrote this piece
um thinking okay uh
this is now that I've split this out
someone's going to want to do a short
problem study never really thinking it
was going to be me
and a few things happen
um
I started getting perspective I started
getting like some very positive things
like I got people from around the world
offering me help to run a Serial problem
study
former students of mine
um who were in other other universities
offered to help
um Iran Ben David who wrote this piece
with me he's a he's a former student of
mine who's now Professor here at
Stanford very prominent uh well-known
infectious disease epidemiologist and
doctor
um he offered to help run the study uh I
got an email from someone in Major
League Baseball Dan Eichner who runs uh
essentially like cheating you know
testing for steroids and stuff for major
league baseball players
he runs this major major independent lab
and he had ordered a whole bunch of
syrup of antibody tests in China these
were short supplies really hard to get
them
but he'd have the four um you know he
basically on the foresight to say look
baseball's going to need them I'm going
to order them for baseball wow and he
had a huge stash of them
um huge I mean he's like 10 000 tests he
had available and he and he called me up
and he said look up
I don't want to use this for baseball I
want to use this for science I want to
use this for public health and I want
you to use them for running a test a
study
and just offer them up to for free make
the space I mean it's just it was a
really good feeling a lot of people were
coming together to try to answer this
really important question how big is the
denominator we really needed to know
this number in order to understand what
the right policy ought to be
um the same time I wrote this piece and
I started getting death threats I got I
got friends of mine who from Stanford
who befriended me on Facebook I got I
got like this system with vilest emails
uh questioning my motives
my motive Brian was to actually just to
understand how large the denominator was
it was a hypothesis and I wanted to test
it
um I mean that's what that's what it
said the the article said that and it
was it was actually kind of shocking to
me
um that an article like this which is to
me was just like a putting forward a
scientific hypothesis would be met with
this kind of vile vile attacks it's
almost like they wanted you know For
Better or For Worse we have all these
you know trainings here in San Diego I'm
sure you have it in Stanford too about
you know how uh toxic Academia is and
and how you know how awful it is and
undoubtedly I mean we're talking to
somebody who had a toxic experience in
Academia but I think they mean you know
typically more you know the student
experience Etc uh universities are
racist elitists you know classists and
some of this is undoubtedly true I mean
my home University was you know it was
founded in part uh because of it you
know need to
de-anti-semitomize you know the location
where the university is they wouldn't
allow Jews to own real estate in the in
the town where UC San Diego is located
yeah you can sell a house to a black a
Mexican or a Jew and that lasts until
the 60 until uh Roger Revell had the
foresight to notice that Jonah Salk uh
couldn't buy a house and next to his
laboratory so that fell all by the
wayside but so Academia has always been
Rife with with sexism and all these
things but when you Advocate you know
the opposite point of view when you say
look we've made a lot of changes
oftentimes you are met with uh and look
I'm a Jew saying that we no longer have
rampant anti-Semitism even though we
have instances on campus it doesn't mean
the campus is anti-Semitic so the point
is it almost seemed like people wanted
it to be a panda like we almost willed
it I mean how else can you explain you
know the vitriol right you're basically
saying like let's collect data and be
agnostic and maybe maybe you didn't
choose the headline I don't think it's
it's certainly uh that should be that
controversial it's a scientific question
uh for a lay audience so what do you
attribute that to the the scientists you
know questioning your motives you
mentioned that happen in your Facebook
befriending which which you know might
ultimately be a good thing because you
filter out who's really your friend I
mean these are people I love and respect
I've worked hard to forgive them in my
own heart I mean you know maybe someday
it's going to be hard to forget that
that uh that they acted this way but you
know it was there was there were so many
them were just scared
um I think part of it uh I mean we
absolutely I think in science think of
ourselves as you know Above The Fray but
we're not really yeah but we're subject
to the same kinds of biases in our
thinking and our knee-jerk reactions and
even prejudices that that everyone is
we're still human Ryan right
um and I think that's that's that that
came out really clearly uh the other
thing around this the the scientists are
already spoken up some of the pro like
the primary uh you know Tony fauci for
instance had already had already
recommended a lockdown these lockdowns
had already been implemented around the
country by March 24th when we wrote this
piece right we'd already been sheltered
we started here in California two weeks
to slow the spread right yeah and this
was like a week and a half into this and
then there was this sense I think of
common purpose around the the the
lockdowns like this at least in in the
in the University communities look we're
doing our best to like work together to
get rid of this disease and here I am
saying well I don't know if we have the
empirical basis to justify the lockdowns
right that's what that's that's what I
wrote I said Let's Do Science to fix it
but it's not popular to do science when
we're all in this together and we're all
like sacrificing together although
actually lockdowns I don't think are
actually a common sacrifice it's it's
really it benefits uh the relatively
well-off in society really hurts the
poor but that we that's that's something
that was in the back of my head also
that the lockdowns are going to be
really quite damaging for poor people
for for children for older people for
vulnerable people
um uh so I you know these I I didn't
view these as Costless I think many many
people thought of because okay we just
do two weeks get rid of the disease and
then move on with our life that was the
story we were told and in the middle of
this I'm saying no no why don't we do it
why don't we just study to see if it's
actually right to do what we just did
and a lot of people have put their
reputations behind what we what we had
just did we asked the entire world
essentially to lock down to stop
it's an extraordinary thing for science
scientists to ask to do and people
listen they did it
um things here you know and UCSD we have
to wear masks and classrooms up until
Reese I taught this whole spring with
the whole classroom was masked except in
the dining Halls we didn't have to wear
masks and and I and I also noticed many
times you know during the pandemic I'd
be commuting and I remember being at
Stanford and seeing the same behavior so
I'm sure it took place there
um young men and women Prime of their
lives super fit on their skateboards you
know going across the quad here there
but a mask uh no helmet mask and on
their phone Jay
incredible uh and the risk assessment
yeah there's something very good about
that actually and we make fun but like
honestly like there's like a deep
empathy underneath that behavior they're
like they're they're afraid not for
themselves but they're like trying to
protect their old older uh professors or
something or their grandma or something
right like there's some empathy
underneath this a public health
weaponized that empathy unfortunately I
think they used people's especially
young people's natural desire to do good
not to gain compliance with behaviors
that actually didn't have a scientific
basis underneath them
um so or had a very inadequate
scientific basis I think underneath them
so I think that's that's part of part of
the legacy of this the other the other
thing I found was like there was some
like aspects of professional jealousy
and like it was you know why am I
running the zero problems I do I do
research in health policy for a living I
do I I write I analyze data that's my
that's my job but I don't generally go
and do zero problem studies this is the
first one I've ever done right so why am
I the one doing it instead of somebody
else who has an experience who's
experienced running these kinds of
studies doing it I mean I personally at
this point would have been quite happy
to like have the CDC run the serial
problem study right uh this is what I
was calling for effect in effect in this
in this you can see that this is the
last sentence of the of the last two
sentences of the of the op-ed uh
Universal quarantine may not be worth
the cost imposed in the economy
Community individual mental and physical
health we should undertake immediate
steps to Value empirical based on the
current lockdowns I thought the CDC
would run this study
that would have bleeded away the
controversy I think because that people
would people view the CDC as a as a
legitimate scientific agency with very
serious people it is a legitimate agency
with serious people that's just that
made tremendous mistakes during the
pandemic right at this point though I
had no no doubts about the cdc's
capacity to run such a study
um but they just didn't do it
it fell on me in part because I wrote
this op-ed it wasn't something I was
seeking right
um anyway so uh we wrote this and uh we
actually did the study yeah
um in April early April 2020 we
collected about 3 000 samples from
um since Santa Clara County it was it
was it was really hard to run this
during a lockdown because people were
afraid to come out to get their blood
collected
um we couldn't get an agreement to go
into nursing homes uh so we only did a
community sample uh sampling was even
hard right so we did this like Facebook
sampling which trying to be very
controversial because what it ended up
doing is it it pulled more people from
the Richer parts of Santa Clara County
whereas the poorer parts are less likely
to be on Facebook they didn't sign up so
we had to do some re-waiting to try to
like get a population level
um
um there was also controversy over the
test kit that we used the test kit
actually turned out to be quite good the
FDA eventually approved the test kit for
emergency use
um it had a false positive rate of 0.5
percent which doesn't sound that high
but if you have a very low prevalence
there's some possibility that you if all
false positives some some very small
possibility uh we corrected for that in
the statistics uh the original version
we put this out as a working paper
um you know like a preprint which then
led to like all these people saying look
you got all the math wrong you did
everything wrong uh when I put this out
it was a whole the world blew up again
um I started getting like uh again more
death threats more more attacks um yeah
there's a lot of like media attention
some positive and some quite unfairly
negative
now which I'll talk about in a second
um the only thing submitted though Jay
this this was published in 2021 so yeah
so we submitted it to like four
different journals and they after the
after the media attacks on us uh it we
basically couldn't get a fair hearing
um and uh you know we we revived I have
to say like the pre-print process I
found actually quite good like I was
really pleased with it in a scientific
sense
um so we got help signed on from
world-class statisticians on how to redo
the standards with error in the very
first version of it and we we corrected
the error in a week thanks to help from
from countless scientists around the
world
um we wanted to measure the the the uh
false positive rate of the test kit we
were using to look for antibodies right
it's very important number yeah
um the the manufacturer had given us a
study out of about I think it was like
400 people that they'd take in stored
blood from 2018 more or less and then
run run the test kit against it now it
should be negative because there's no
covet in 2018 right so any positives you
see are false positives and in that in
that stored blood study they had they
came out with this point five percent it
turned out and we found out after we
released the preprint that there were
labs around the world that were trying
to check the false positive rate of this
antibody test kit and they sent us their
results for use in our study wow and so
we went from like 400 uh samples for
checking for for false models rate to
like 3 000 samples in a week
um it's just people just shared the
result this was how science ought to be
done we're working together as
scientists to help each other understand
the physical world and the preprint
process was really fantastic for that it
also led to like a lot of bad things
like you know there are all these
Twitter attacks
um uh there was a uh we by the way we uh
I think science really needs to be
replicated yeah so uh for so this I
really like the study I think we got the
result right I'll tell you the results
in a second uh but um but we did another
Sierra problem study in in LA county the
week after that 10th through 11th of
April
um uh with the same test kit but with a
very different sampling scheme here we
hired a professional firm that had a
representative sample of LA county and
we sampled them and so we had no fight
over whether we had the representation
correct and
um I'll tell you the results so the
results were one they were um do I have
it here
um 50 times more infections than cases
50 times more infections for every
person that had been identified by
public health as being positive there
are 50 people or 40 people walking
around L.A county or Santa Clara County
that had um that had tested that tested
that had antibody positive meaning that
they they were they had been both
disease recovered some many of them I'm
like maybe 30 of them didn't even
remember having symptoms so this disease
then produces a very wide range of
clinical outcomes not no symptoms at all
you just recover not even knowing that
you were sick to these horrible severe
vile pneumonia was killing people no
right um but we were focused on the
viral pneumonia when in fact there was a
big uh you know uh sort of Iceberg
underneath of lots of lots of people
that it had that had this uh there's
three lessons to this one is that the
death rate was 0.2 percent 99.8 survival
in the community now we didn't sample
nursing homes is much higher there right
um uh the the second the disease was
already too far gone in early April to
stop it three percent or four percent of
the population had already had covet
that means the zero code if you you may
as well forget about zero code this
disease is here to stay and it's likely
to infect a very large fraction of the
population before it's done we knew that
in early April 2020
from this study
um and then um and then the third thing
it's only three or four percent of the
population that we measured having this
that means the disease still has quite a
long way to go we're in for a long
epidemic all right those are three
lessons to be learned from this and I
don't think anyone wanted to learn any
of those lessons because from that from
the hate mail I got from from these
studies
um this this paper was published in the
Journal of American Medical Association
the LA County one which we didn't
release through a pre-print process and
so it didn't get quite the same
notoriety controversy but it was the
same very similar methodology and went
through peer review and published in one
of the top medical journals almost
immediately
um with me as a senior author
um so you know it's one of these things
where like
um I thought we were doing good science
I still think we did good science here
but yeah I mean what could possibly be
political a month after this I mean it
was advocating against I mean this isn't
even navigating for against the lockdown
I mean it's you know it's just it's a
it's a key scientific fact that we need
to know to decide whether a lockdown may
be worth it or not I had Eric topal on
the podcast about a year and a half ago
um when we're still in the Delta wave I
think it was and you know I I didn't
really push on him as hard as I probably
should have I mean um you know it's hard
when you're talking to somebody and you
want to establish a rapport and you want
them to speak freely and and not feel
like they're on 60 Minutes but you know
one of the things I I
um I'm embarrassed to say I I really
didn't push him hard on the on his
political uh involvement in the uh in
the release you know choosing
effectively to Advocate at least I mean
he wasn't in control of it but he
Advocate against releasing the uh the
results of the of the at least the
Pfizer contact vaccine results prior to
the election and part of it was you know
at least reported in the public I can't
you know vouch for this and maybe you
know more about it but there there may
have been political ramifications around
that and I didn't ask him about that but
if I could go back and do the interview
again
um you know I would ask him uh if if
this as in he's a huge proponent of the
vaccine as you know he and I did speak
about uh but um but given that you know
there were people that didn't take the
vaccine because it was not released
until after the election or results at
least the results of the trial study
were not released until after November
whatever 9th or 8th of of 2020.
um that means people died right Jay I
mean people died that could have been
saved you're not an anti-vaxxer you're
vaccinated I advocated for the vaccine
you advocate for the vaccine so that
means people died right because let's
just take Eric out of it okay so let's
just say people that didn't want the
vaccine and said I won't take a vaccine
a trump vaccine
um then then isn't it safe to say that
people died because of for political
basically purposes I mean you can't have
it both you can't say the vaccine worked
and say it was a good thing to withhold
the vaccine for any period of time
during a raging Inferno uh it's like
it's like withholding a fire
extinguisher Am I Wrong well I just to
defend Eric although I think he's um
and he's a he he is a good scientist and
he's tried tried his best but I do think
I do and I do think I agree with you
that he politicized
um his science and his advocacy in a way
that was really quite harmful but just
to defend like you you know when you
release
um when the FDA says look we have enough
information to recommend that to allow a
firm to Market some product you have to
have some confidence that they've done
this testing right
and so in principle you could say well
look Eric's just saying let the FDA do
its work uh don't let there be political
pressure to release the study early or
whatever uh that would be my sort of
attempt to try to defend Eric
um I I I do think though that that
wasn't just all of it like I I actually
worked with the FDA on vaccine safety
for almost a decade
helping them with like measuring uh
statistical systems to measure vaccine
safety and Drug safety
um uh I mean there's some great
scientists there uh but the pressure on
the FDA on both sides was really truly
something horrible to watch
um I think like for instance now it's
been very they've been very slow to
release data on on whether the vaccines
show FIT safety signals it that
undermines confidence in vaccines when
you when you see a political an agency
there's not supposed to be political
right back politically and it's also the
same thing for scientists for for
scientists to act politically when in
fact we're just supposed to be supposed
to try to just follow the data no matter
what where it leads for politics I think
like when Eric wrote that letter
um encouraging the the the slower
release of the theft of the of the of
the vaccine data or the FDA approval of
it it really struck me as political
struck me as like he was more concerned
about about uh Trump winning than he was
about yeah that's what I'm referring to
you know yeah but I guess I want to push
back on you with love and respect but
say if you could do it again Jay knowing
that um the results that you published
in the 2021 study that were done in 2020
and then this study is currently on the
screen you these have life-saving
potential they may have been tainted the
acceptance of them the hate mail death
threats
um those may not have happened of course
counterfactual history is impossible but
you know we have a Multiverse in
cosmology so let me just ask the
question do you regret publishing the
op-ed uh in that it may have you know
biased ordinary clear-headed people uh
to reject the work of you as an eminent
scientist and your many many colleagues
two different studies showing the same
thing
um do you regret the op-ed do you feel
like it was counterproductive in the
long sweep of History would you do it
again I would do it in a heartbeat I
didn't have a choice like I had a
hypothesis that I thought was very
important from a scientific perspective
and also a policy perspective not
politics but policy perspective that's
my job Brian I mean you know it's like
it's like you having an idea about where
to look in the universe to resolve
fundamental customer logical questions
you'd have to do it it's just part of
who you are yeah right you have to you
have to try to follow through the same
thing with here this was my job like
this is this is my the purpose of my my
work was to have this hypothesis have
hypothesis like this and test them no
matter what the what the costs are uh to
me personally that is yeah um so I just
I would do it again in a heartbeat I I
mean the politicization was you know by
March of 2020 it was already people were
already like you know Trump has already
screwed up everything and uh that they
were you know there was in this
environment where especially in
academics
um there's a lot of hate for Trump yeah
I think it's sort of the color people's
thinking about about this and so like
people thought saw these studies and
what Trump had said things like well we
don't want the the the cure to be worse
than the disease right meaning the
lockdowns you don't want to be you don't
want to do lockdowns if they hurt people
I mean just because Trump said it
doesn't mean it's wrong right I mean
that's absolutely true you don't want
the cure to be worse than the disease
right
um and so we I I think there was this
like sort of especially in the
scientific Community this knee-jerk
reaction against Trump as if he were
some uniquely bad thing
right and so therefore anybody who sided
with him or aided him became tainted
with the taint of trump you know the
scarlet letter T
um including you I think I mean you yeah
again I saw you uh in the public long
before I met you uh advocating common
sense you're very sober you have a
gravitas you're uh you know if I had to
Define you you know I know you're a
God-fearing man I know you're a
wonderful devout Christian family man
but I think of you as scientists and by
the way that's a compliment for me
because I don't think most Physicians
are scientists at least the ones that I
teach you know that kind of say like
will this be on the test and um it used
to be that that Physicians and
physicists there was an actual
connection between the terms uh but it
but it really has dissipated but I think
you are you are a true scientist at
heart and you're a doctor second and I'm
not diminishing your role as a doctor
but at all I'm just saying you are I'm
primarily a researcher this is that's
where my that's that's where my
inclinations are I don't I don't see
patients Brian what I do for a living is
I do research for them if I'm not a
scientist then I'm not that's not I
don't know what to call myself yeah
exactly all right yeah so let's uh after
the study then yeah so like what
happened next was really kind of
shocking so I'll get back to this there
was a series of Articles uh May 2020 uh
April 2020 uh by uh this I just picked
on this BuzzFeed author who's like
actually she was obsessed with me um I
called my friends and I started calling
her job there after the Les Mis you know
the kind of like the the inspector in
Les Mis or whatever I mean um she she
wanted to she wanted to create a scandal
around the study around any any
activities so involved in the study was
this guy this man named Johnny and
needies who I believe is the most highly
cited author in existence that's still
living yeah um I mean he he uh he was he
is an amazing man truly one of the
probably the smartest man I've ever met
I mean he had an incredible energy he
had written um for instance to expose
theranos you know the Elizabeth Holmes
fraud very early uh he uh wrote a paper
in in 20 2005 essentially saying look uh
95 of all published medical studies
around and you know what you read the
paper and you're like at the end of it
you're like yeah he's right 95 of all
medical studies are wrong it's like a
five-page paper or whatever and just
it's he's just a brilliant man and he as
a result of his work there's been this
like replicability Crisis that's I think
improved uh you know psychology
economics yeah I spoke with uh Guido in
Benz at Stanford uh Nobel Laureate about
that very topic and and the CR that's
called The credibility Revolution that
he in part one the Nobel Prize for it's
exactly correct yeah yeah so I think I
think uh John unities was a is uh was
like he the fact that he was in this
study he'd also created a generate a lot
of enemies through his career because he
just called out bad science yeah um and
many of them stacked their heads up to
try to get back at him and uh he was a
senior author in the Santa Clara study
uh funny it's like the Santa Clara study
uh got all this like nasty attacks the
L.A County study where he wasn't an
author didn't get nearly as many nasty
attacks and he's kind of a clean
experiment if you ask me
um but anyways what happened was that
this this BuzzFeed author she decided
that that we were bad guys yeah
um so like you know one of the things
for that Santa Clara study he was a big
community of people that was that tried
to help like my wife for instance
volunteered to help she negotiated we
couldn't find any place that would allow
us to have this like we had this like
drive-through finger prick check of
blood blood draws right so like people
are washing their groceries I mean let's
not forget this illness and people were
going totally nuts and I actually have a
theory Jay that part of it was because
of the movie
um uh
Matt Damon won uh because all that stuff
and you could just see these journalists
you know watching that movie oh there's
fomite and there's this and it all of a
sudden became in the literature and what
were people doing during during the
panda they were watching Netflix and
what was the most popular movie uh
contagion and um there's so many things
in that from from you know the
transmission the zoonotic that all I
think got imprinted on the base layer on
these journalist minds and uh as opposed
to doing real sound scientific research
and into verifying checking sources Etc
uh they relied on kind of that pop
knowledge but anyway I don't want to
derail you or you were no I mean that's
exactly what happened right I think I
think because and so like people were
scared to like sign up for their study
yeah they didn't want to be face to face
with someone drawing a lot so what we
did is we had this drive-through blood
draw so people like drove up they stuck
their finger out the almost closed
window and did a little prick got a
little blood prick and then they drove
drove hot it was it was hard to organize
we had to get uh like my church uh
agreed to let uh they use our parking
lot as a drive-through and my wife
helped arranged that and she might
watched a physician she wrote this email
to her to my kids Middle School list
serve without asking me she was doing
this because out of her out of her her
sense that she wanted to like help
um but she actually asking people to
sign up for the study now we had a
Facebook sampling I really didn't want
people to randomly sign up Stanford
professors were calling me wanting to
sign up for the study because they
wanted to know their antibody test lab
antibody levels
um and I had to say no I myself never
checked my antibody levels till months
later because I felt like we had such a
scarce resource in these animal test
kits
um yeah anyway so uh Stephanie Lee this
BuzzFeed author uh made a scandal out of
it somebody leaked that email that my
wife sent to my kids Middle School list
serve and she made my wife into this bad
guy a Stanford professor's wife
recruited people for his coronavirus
study by clammy would revealed if they
could return to work without fear
because she made the the claim that if
you have an antibody it's likely that
you're immune in that now turns out that
that having antibodies being exposed to
Covenant recovering does provide
immunity that's absolutely true
um but by the way fauci said he was
ignorant on that question and not you
know one way or another that's stupid
but just he was agnostic they didn't
know as of last year I believe in other
words they had never done a natural
immunity study and to my knowledge I
don't know if the CDC or n Aid or
whatever the agency is have they ever
done a natural immunity study it
yeah they finally I mean they finally
acknowledged it uh relatively recently
shockingly because you know by Earl by
eight in late April uh when this
BuzzFeed author wrote this thing it was
still quite controversial whether there
was immunity or not after recovery um
but by like the middle of the summer it
was really clear from Reading like cell
and nature studies and cell nature of
immunity especially like cellular
immunity was pretty strong after you
after you covered recovered
um that question there was some
uncertainty I think in April not so much
uncertainty by like July of 25 I
basically decided from reading that
literature that that that there was
pretty pretty solid evidence in favor of
I didn't know how long was last um that
you need long-term epidemiological
studies but now we've now we've had them
uh it seems to last up until until you
get a new variant but even if you get a
new vary the second time you get it is
likely to be less severe than the first
time you get it right
um anyway so she wrote this study and I
got to tell you Brian I was filled with
anxiety now all of a sudden my wife was
this National negative story she's a
she's a she's now brought into this
she's just a civilian in this right well
it's one thing to attack me I mean I
wasn't really emotionally prepared for
that either at the time but to attack my
family I felt like my life was out of
control I couldn't protect my my own my
own wife I was worried about my kids
because now I have this notoriety and
maybe the the teachers or someone will
take take action against them or worse
I'm getting death threats right
um and and I was I lost 30 pounds of
anxiety weight I mean I could have stood
to lose it actually Brian actually to be
honest but like that's not the right way
to do it within like two a month and a
half I'd lost a tremendous amount of
weight I couldn't sleep it was really
really um it was like it was a dark time
for me of course um she she wrote
another piece saying JetBlue's founder
helped fund a Stanford study and said
the chronographs wasn't that deadly now
the study we ran it for about a hundred
thousand dollars which is very cheap for
a study of that size
um and it was funded by small dollar
donations to Stanford I didn't take a
single penny for the study
um and Stanford knew this that one of
the people that donated the study was
this man uh who found a Jet Blue
um I'd had a couple conversations and he
wanted me to run studies in New York
City but I didn't have the
infrastructure to run studies anywhere
other than just where I happened to have
local connections like LA and Santa
Clara so that didn't go anywhere but it
was very generous he gave five thousand
dollars to Stanford for the study
um and uh uh somehow that turned into
this like weird conflict of interest
it's normally how studies are funded
like this Anonymous gift account given
to Stanford yeah I'm not going to change
the result of my studies because the
JetBlue founder gave five thousand
dollars for a hundred thousand dollar
study it's insane
um and but that was the app and she
wrote it a Stanford whistleblower
complained alleges
right Stanford then took that and
started uh first they called it an
investigation but then very quickly they
called it a fact-finding thing saying we
didn't do anything wrong they just
wanted to find out what happened
um it lasted months I hired lawyers it
was it was I was really you know I've
never had anything like this happen I'm
a faculty full professor in good
standing yeah um to have my University
take this kind of slur seriously was
really a shock to me
um and uh during that during that they
you know they they questioned basically
everything I I during the summer I wrote
a piece I'll show you here on the
futility of contact tracing because if
you have a highly infectious respiratory
virus contract racing is really useful
if you can identify easily who gave it
to you you're not the disease isn't
spreading rapidly I wrote this piece
saying look if you have a disease like
this this is contact racing it's not
going to work to stop the Spread spread
of it it just seems like a reason you
mean just such an easy thing it turned
out to be correct now everyone
understands the contact racing programs
didn't do very much
um in retrospect but at the time this is
somewhat a controversial thing this is
published in September but I wrote it in
July and I gave some public appearances
about on this in July and August 2020.
this was part of their investigation why
did I talk about contact racing
in this negative way yeah um you know
I'm a faculty member I thought I had
academic freedom and yet Stanford
treated my uh my professional opinion
about the about about the whether
contractor can be useful as something
that to investigate me over they
investigated the study knowing full well
that the study was funded appropriately
that we weren't there was no conflict of
interest in this in how the study was
funded yeah what's the implication that
you know the founder of JetBlue is no
longer involved in the company and a
daily operational budget that somehow
this will re down to his benefit and and
that you knew who who funded your
research in a pooled set of donations to
what the third wealthiest campus uh by
endowment size in the world I mean it
was truly a shocking thing I mean as I
said I hired Dolores it was I was again
filled with it it was just it was a very
anxious summer actually I have to say
like at the end of it
um uh even before the end of it I'd come
to terms with this I was like okay I'm
gonna I'm this is just the way life is
gonna be I have to just accept that
basically everything I say is going to
seen in this like this conspiracy feel
feel kind of feel kind of a way instead
of like my the the good faith method the
good faith in which I meant it like if
we found for instance that covid was 3.4
mortality rate I would have reported
that I wanted to know the truth I really
desperately wanted to know that number
because the the the the the the the the
right policy depends on knowing that
number
um uh Johnny Unitas organized the group
that he wanted to like he wrote to
president Trump's uh and and said look
uh you you I want to offer you the uh
some outside scientific help in the
organized a group of scientists to to go
visit with President Trump including
people who were very much in favor of
the lockdowns that group included both
Pro and anti-lockdown scientists he
wanted to give president Trump a full
view of the scientific range of opinion
was about about coven
um Stephanie made it into a big deal
yeah as if somehow it was like weird
that scientists would want to go inform
policy makers on this key scientific
question presenting fairly what the
range of scientific opinion was
at least he compliments you you know
I mean you know whatever I just the
whole thing was just uh and then then uh
this is after this she wrote a piece
after he wrote The Great Barrier
declaration about how we were calling
for her to immunity which is such
nonsense
um like you know well let me tell that
story in just a bit all right
um so there was a now there were a
hundred of these criminal studies that
were done they all basically said the
same thing uh and the the key thing is
not even the death rate itself but the
spread in age as a risk factor of the as
a death rate right so you have like for
for kids the survival rate is like
really really high 99.99 I mean just a
very large very very high number pretty
close to 100 for older people it's quite
a deadly disease you know especially in
nursing homes institutions less of 70
and up 94.5 94.5 survival that's that's
a low survival rate for a single
infectious disease
um and it and in fact that's come to
pass like that's the predictions of
these studies 80 of the deaths have been
people over 65 worldwide
right and for for kids
um it's it's likely that even even
before we had the vaccines it was less
damaging than the flu
for kids
um the lockdowns for the kids is a
really bad thing uh so I I think uh it's
one of these things where like I just I
don't know what to say it's just it was
shocking
um but the scientifically it was quite
quite nice we had a replication of our
of our finding in real time within
within a year we knew that we were right
from a hundred other studies now let me
tell you the story this great American
decoration so you get an apology from
Stephanie no no she's still she still
thinks we're bad guys
um
uh I mean I think it's just really hard
to do science in this kind of
environment and you think science
writers would try to make science easier
to do not harder but that's not what
happened during the pandemic
um
so the great reaction declaration when
we uh that wasn't the thing that I wrote
in October of 2020 with uh Martin
koldorf who's on the left over here and
and soon after Gupta we wrote this
worthless thing because we what we
wanted to do is we this was aimed at the
public it was less aimed at scientists
we wanted to tell the public at the time
it was like there's we could see another
lockdown is coming we knew that there
was going to be another wave of cases
and that people were going to react with
as a lockdown there was a sense there
was an elu there was an illusion of
consensus that everyone all reasonable
signs are in favor of a lockdown what we
want to do is we want to tell the public
no there are reasonable scientists that
disagreed with the lockdown policy right
reasonable scientists with credentials
so we wrote this for it's like a
one-page document tens of thousands of
scientists signed on epidemiologists
signed on almost a million people signed
on
um and the idea was uh we set this the
idea of the great branch of that
question is that is we advocated for
Focus protection of older people those
are the ones who are at higher risk move
Heaven and Earth to protect them at the
same time the lockdowns were hurting
younger people
um I'll show you some evidence on this
in a second but like in poor countries
the lockdown is essentially what we did
is that we disrupted trade ties
in poor countries where the poorest
people live it's that the point the end
of that policy is that they lose their
jobs two dollars a day or less of income
they go into dire poverty they they
starve their kids starve
um and and our kids in richer countries
you stop schooling for even short time
that has long long-term consequences on
their lives they're less well educated
so that means they're going to be poor
their whole lives they're going to live
be less healthy and they're going to
live less long we robbed our kids of
Life eaters with this school closure
policy that we adopted and so the
lockdowns we thought were quite harmful
for for uh for the less on net harmful
for Less vulnerable people for all for
for more vulnerable people
um you want to have an earth protect
them Focus production that's what the
great branch and Declaration was and we
uh we wrote this as an alternative to
like letting it letting the virus rip
we're not calling for letting the virus
go everywhere we wanted to protect older
people from this uh from the virus but
we also thought The lockdown policy was
a mistake
we're on October 4th 2020.
within days tens of thousands and I just
signed on better protection for older
high-risk people young adults may live
near normal lives as best you can to
avoid to minimize the collateral damage
from the lockdowns let kids play with
their friends let them go to school let
them have something close to a normal
life yeah or else we're going to harm
them
um
okay now I was much more emotionally
prepared for this because I'd already
been through the fire in uh by April and
the summer of 2020 uh so I knew there
was going to get a tax what I didn't
know was who was going to attack
four days after he wrote the great
parenting declaration this is Francis
Collins he's the head of the National
Institute of Health uh just to give some
context to your listeners someone like
uh Francis Collins
plays a pivotal role in the careers of
biomedical research scientists
um he sits on top of tens of billions of
dollars of money that goes to biomedical
research in the US and elsewhere but
it's more than that in order to get
tenure at a place like Stanford
University medicine you basically need
to have an NIH Grant it's a signifier of
success it's like it's like it's like an
NSF Grant maybe in in in
cosmology or something I mean I just I
just don't I you know I just the
equivalent is hard to say but it's
really quite important in the social
status of scientists in biomedicine he
wrote this email four days after he
wrote The Great branch of operation and
let me just read it to you
um uh hi Tony and Cliff Cliff my Tony is
Tony fauci yeah Francis Collins writing
to Tony fauci uh see uh this is the
great branch and declaration site this
proposal from the three Fringe
epidemiologists Harvard Stanford Oxford
mind you um with the secretary Secretary
of HHS seems to be getting a lot of
attention even a co-signature from a
Nobel Prize winner Mike Levin to
Stanford I mean you know it's Fringe
because the Nobel Prize winner signed on
uh there needs to be a quick and
devastating published takedown of his
premises I don't see anything like that
online yet is it underway
I started getting calls from reporters
almost immediately asking why do I want
to let the buyer strip why do I want to
kill grandma what was wrong with me to
suggest to suggest uh that this Fringe
idea uh New York Times wrote this
basically a hit piece a really quite
unfair hit piece essentially saying the
idea was that you couldn't you couldn't
do Focus protection it's impossible to
protect it you can you can lock down
everyone keep everyone safe but you
couldn't keep old people safe so that's
crazy it's actually not true uh Sweden
had actually followed up after a
disaster in a Stockholm in an early in
the pandemic they followed a policy
Focus protection that after that
disaster actually did manage to keep a
lot of their older populations safe
uh uh you know Trump wants to try for
herd immunity without a vaccine it could
kill Millions
um these are fellow scientists writing
this uh I mean it was it was truly issue
because the co-author yeah the CDC
director the now current CDC director um
the uh the what I wanted was a
conversation among Public Health
officials to say how should we protect
vulnerable older people it's gonna be
very different in LA county you know
versus in you know Billings Montana or
something you need local public health
to weigh in who understand the living
circumstances of the older population
where they are and divides local
policies for for uh that are sort of
tailored for the local population that's
what should have happened a detailed
conversation instead you had this crazy
idea that we're trying for her it
doesn't make any scientific sense herd
immunity is the end point of this
pandemic
I mean that's just how all the other
coronaviruses are controlled the other
chronoviruses you have a sufficient
fraction of the population that had it
you can have it again
um it doesn't protection doesn't last
forever but it's but you get this
decoupling of cases from deaths that's
what herd immunity works like and isn't
lockdown of everybody implicit in that
lockdown of elderly people so why why
would it be harder to lock down fewer
people than to lock down more people I
mean we weren't even calling for a
lockdown we were looking I'm not even
saying lockdowns
protection you're absolutely right it
made no logical sense other than to say
uh other than that just they didn't like
us or something for in Japanese we were
trusted colleagues saying look there's
there's not a consensus here we're in uh
Galileo's house his final uh uh a house
slash uh imprisonment location and we
both remarked you know it wasn't a bad
place to do a you know a couple year
stint as a prisoner you know compared to
that I think Jeffrey Epstein would have
loved to trade places
um but while we were there you know we
couldn't help think about well what did
Galileo face you know when he is facing
you know a modern day uh you know a
Latter-Day version earlier day version
of an inquisition and I'm actually
calling this episode a scientific
Inquisition because there's so many uh I
don't think a general as you say uh year
tenure you know you have multiple
degrees all from Stanford uh your career
you know and I'm not minimizing because
you got huge uh repercussions to your
career I mean you could have been a
terminated a gig you have health
insurance you have all sorts of things
that you depend on your career for and
you should and you have every right to
uh but there are younger people on all
of these articles and younger people
doing good science now they are tainted
with this uh with this scarlet letter f
um not for fauci but for uh but for uh
Fringe and that's devastating and I
don't even think the the results can be
known I don't even think it's knowable I
don't think Francis is going through and
putting his finger on the scale of every
uh proposal but when you say is there a
coordinated you know it's a conspiracy I
mean that's the definition of conspiracy
right people breathing together is what
it means and breathing here to you know
coordinate with the uh with the you know
number one uh person in the world uh who
is the face of this pandemic and leading
the marshalling of resources uh now his
uh his uh his quotes are accurate but
will not be appreciated by the White
House
um yeah I mean he's calling us Fringe
epidemiology I mean it's just such an
irresponsible use of his power Brian
it's such an irresponsible piece of his
power if he didn't agree with us he
could say why he didn't agree with us
not calling for I mean they used the
press to attack us to the smear us to
essentially to push us to The Fringe on
why because they wanted to create this
illusion that they actually was a
scientific consensus when there actually
wasn't one right um yeah by the way I
don't remember you know Millions not
dying Jay I remember I I think the death
I remember the very vividly the front
page of the New York Times with a
hundred thousand names very powerful
very moving uh we're up to 10 times that
I haven't seen any you know full issues
of the Washington Post with everybody's
name on it why is that I mean this this
it's got linked up in politics really
not very quickly didn't it
um and uh you know Tony fauci I think
worked to undermine president Trump
there's no other way to put it um and I
just that's unfortunately he's a
Scientific Advisor he's not supposed to
take political sides
um he did right they're talking about
how they're going to manipulate the
White House they were scared about us
because not because of of of anything of
like we were right or wrong they were
scared of us because they were afraid
the illusion of consensus that they had
that they were the science they knew
what the scientific thing to do was
um had been shattered you have Nobel
Prize winners you have uh uh your
doctors and epidemiologists from from
Stanford Harvard Oxford saying look no
we don't we disagree that should be a
call to Scientific discussion not a call
for devastating takedowns it and then
have it yeah what you say is absolutely
correct I mean it's chilling you know to
think about that I want every scientist
who's watching imagine your research
proposal and we have people in my field
by the way Jay that claim they're being
censored by the big cosmology and NASA
and there are people that propose you
know Flat Earth uh observatories and
okay so there has to be some level but
just every scientist and I have many and
many of the Nobel Prize winners that
have been on the show
um and honored Me by by coming on
they're watching this right now just
imagine you know your next proposed
whether it's your University whether
it's to your um you know to your funding
agency imagine just forget about the
politics just the the grant director
thinks of you as a fringe as a as a nut
case as a crank that not only you know
it wasn't that you need to be ignored or
you know or we need to bring the
scientific no that's your crackpot and
you need to be taken down
um I don't care what branch of science
you pursue I I think it's I think it's
it's really quite chilling and the fact
that that they're still in position it
even though yeah let's say they were
right I don't think that they were right
but let's say they were to do this and
have it revealed via these uh really
damning messages I think that they're
they're they shouldn't be fit to serve
in this capacity and I'm sure that's
controversial to say but that they're
still there and that they're retiring
and they're going to get their benefits
and so forth uh I think scientists
should be outraged about the way you
were treated well I think I think
they've abdicated there was the the
responsibility they had to treat the
power they were they were honored with
um to treat it responsibly right so if
if you if if you're in that position
Brian what you'll do is you would bring
me in and to have a discussion with me
and and you you know if let's say you
disagreed with me you'd say why and uh
if it made sense we'd like air our
differences publicly on on the substance
of it you're not going to use like what
happens when Tony facci does this is a
sense you're absolutely right just sends
a signal to all the other scientists in
biomedicine that if you step out of line
you know if attorney says I am the
science you know if you disagree with me
you're disagreeing with science itself
if you step out of line your career is
at stake
that is that's just shocking right so I
it's yeah you're right there needs to be
obviously some some level of of
gatekeeping you don't you don't want
every crank idea but this was not a
crank idea these were prominent people
in respected institutions stay saying
look this is this policy is wrong and
our intercept the policy was wrong the
disease spread everywhere we still also
got the collateral damage from it um I I
think um it's it's just an irresponsible
use of power and I agree with you I I
don't I don't I don't understand uh and
it frankly it shocked me because I
respected deeply respected Francis
Collins and Antonio before the pandemic
I still have a textbook from 2015 that I
learned internal medicine from
um and Francis Collins you know he's
he's a great he's a very prominent
Christian in and also a prominent
scientist who did amazing work with
Human Genome Project yeah it saddens me
to have to to say negative things about
him I still respect I can't help but
respect him deeply let me ask you a
couple of other questions that I know
your your time is very limited but
there's a couple of you know big picture
questions I want to ask you if you have
uh five more minutes left Jake sure yeah
this first one is um uh you know
revolves around uh the recent um op-ed
he wrote Newsweek where do you see
things going
um uh you know in with with President
Biden
um do you think there'll be a shift
after the midterm elections you feel
like uh the policy uh is sort of we've
reached the point where we're coming to
the as you know people are saying even
uh Joe Biden said you know covet is the
pandemic is over but we're still dealing
I don't know he said something like that
um what do you see that going and then I
want to ask you about this amnesty
proposal and then we'll close out with
some existential questions so first that
Newsweek uh op-ed that you wrote last
week yeah so I think uh whether it's
Biden someone else we have that we have
a choice to make there's two ways I
think we can deal with with future
pandemics one is that what we did what
we did previously which is we uh did
work to try to bring viruses from the
wild into Labs play with them to see if
they have Pandemic potential try to
develop vaccines early and then and then
and then and then try to deal with the
pandemics as they come up try the idea
is to prevent the pandemics and if and
if they happen
um be prepared to deal with them
it's quite likely or certainly possible
at least that the the pandemic this
pandemic may have been caused by that
very research if there's a lab leak it's
because somebody brought a bat virus
that's very close to sarskov too into a
lab
played with it
gave it the capacity to infect humans
and it leaked accidentally that's that's
I'm not saying that's happened for sure
but it's certainly a live hypothesis and
if that's true the the that strategy of
dealing with pandemics
will will have that forever with us if
we if we if we keep keep that the other
path we can just say is not do that we
could we go back the old ways and
sometimes pandemics happen every 30 40
years and just have to try to cope with
that fact right um uh the other thing
about once you have this strategy of
having this like vaccine-ready pandemic
that the Biden plan says within 130 days
we'll have a vaccine and we'll send it
out to the population as soon as there's
a new pandemic happens
um the problem with that is that it
takes longer to test a vaccine in 130
days
um you don't you need you need you know
very large samples of people tens of
thousands maybe hundreds of thousands of
people depending on the on the sample uh
the the uh the statistical power
um to test it you want to test it for a
longer period than just three months to
see if it works you want to know if it
stops transmission you know who it
protects side effects and so on it's
gonna take longer during that time where
you wait for 130 days for the vaccine
there'll be a tremendous pressure to
lock down again yeah so the that's one
path
study vaccines studies study these these
viruses bring them out from the wild
maybe cause the pandemic and then lock
down every time we have it for hopes of
finding a vaccine that we hope Works
after 130 days the other path is a much
more restricted
um set of research to to try to prepare
for pandemics by General vaccine
research General antiviral research not
specific ones to enhance the capacity of
viruses to uh to uh to uh to infect
humans and not by promising 130 day
effectively a vaccine program that
undermines the ability to attempt to
actually test vaccines appropriately and
that potentially undermines the Trust In
vaccines I think those are the policy
choices very starkly that we face you
know whether it's President Biden or
somebody else those are the choices we
have to make in the next few years I
think yeah and then on the last uh topic
before we close out has to do with this
recent proposal uh by uh I think a
professor and maybe some other
colleagues uh of hers and that was uh
it's we need a we need a period of what
we call in Hebrew teshuva repentance and
and maybe forgiveness and she called it
I think the title is amnesty we need an
amnesty uh for what we did and said you
know in Vegas uh you know shouldn't stay
in Vegas what we didn't said during the
the covet pandemic I always loved that
in Vegas you know what what happened
like God doesn't know what's happening
there but anyway uh so God knows uh you
know what what should be done but what
what do you make of this a call for
amnesty so it's a professor Emily Oster
we're actually friends with before the
pandemic still friends but I still have
a deep respect for her
um during the pandemic she's done some
really constructive things like she
collected data on the safety of school
reopening and what played a pretty
Central role in pushing for school
reopening in the United States
um the same time she's called for things
that I disagree with like she called for
vaccine mandates which I think were
quite harmful because I think it read
distrust in vaccines
um uh now I think um the call for
amnesty is hard I very strongly believe
in forgiveness uh I'm called to forgive
I mean this is one of the things that my
my religious upbringing just as it says
like even even people that haven't asked
for forgiveness I'm supposed to I'm
supposed to love my enemies right right
um and so like how do I do that I think
uh the way I think about this is you
have to have forgiveness for people but
not for not amnesty for systems
right we have to have an honest
conversation about what went wrong
we have to have an honest conversation
about so that we can do reform so that
what went wrong doesn't happen again and
that's gonna it's gonna bruise the egos
of some people that's inevitable but
that's how you do system reforms I
personally will work very hard in my own
heart and mind to forgive those people
that have harmed me
um and I call for everybody else to do
the same that's really we need some kind
of reconciliation a lot of mistakes
happened a lot of it was because of fear
a lot of it was because of uncertainty
and those are all understandable
um let's try to work with each other in
that Spirit even Tony fauci I'm willing
to forgive even Francis Collins I'm
willing to forgive but you know in
Judaism at least you're called to
forgive as well but uh but only on the
supposition the person identifies what
was done wrong uh recognizes admits it
is done wrong and uh and also you know
reconciles with him or herself to never
do it again
um and so only it's it's thought you
know can someone's uh honesty really be
tested if they're put in the same
position and unfortunately they're very
likely to be put in position uh and so
um you don't have to react to that but
but is the thing is I think I think some
people we really need a new leadership
like leadership that essentially abuses
its its responsibilities
um doesn't deserve to be leaders right
now I don't I don't mean that personally
I mean it's just like you need people in
scientific leadership and uh that have
the the capacity to do the right thing
even when it's hard yeah um and
unfortunately I don't think that's true
for all of our leaders uh that's not the
same thing as not not forgiving them I
mean I think there should be
consequences for for uh for bad actions
um and that that may include loss of
leadership
yeah and I just closed with a quote from
uh President Eisenhower of course did a
lot of amazing things including you know
uh starting NASA uh but um and
advocating against you know uh the blind
acceptance of a uh what he called a
military-industrial complex and I wonder
you know he also said the following he
said yet in holding scientific research
and Discovery and respect we must also
be alert to the danger that public
policy could itself become captive of a
scientific technological Elite and so um
I think we do need to pay pay heat a
good old Ike uh and and respect it even
as and as scientists who have the most
gain under uh you know benevolent
dictatorship of you know our techno uh
ocracy uh theocracy replace with
scientific uh uh theologians High
priests uh priestesses we need to be
careful of the power that we have you
know you say science to somebody are
like oh my God you guys are so so smart
and you know I always say I have to sing
the alphabet song you know to know what
comes after cubed
the final four thrilling questions of
the into the impossible podcast kind of
semi-rapid fire but I want to ask you
these questions which all my uh
wonderful guests uh have had the
opportunity to to answer and the first
one they're basically advice to your to
the Future generations and past uh
advice to your former self so the first
one I always ask is what would you put
in your ethical will not Material will
when you spring forth uh the age of 120
or now you're so fit you know I was like
the gain of function could be good like
I lost a lot of weight when I had
coveted I put it all back on since I was
in Italy with you you're forcing that
carbonara pasta down I mean no uh but uh
but but in in all seriousness you know
there could be some some good uh gain of
function just not with pathogens please
uh anyway what do you say that you want
to leave in your what we call in Hebrew
is an ethical will uh that that Moses
gave Jacob gave Jesus gave on The Sermon
on the Mount uh even Alfred Nobel has an
ethical component what ethical uh uh
Provisions do you would you like to give
to Future Generations both both
biological and ideological of which I
count myself as one
[Music]
I think you've been each of us have been
given
a purpose intellectual gifts moral gifts
you know it's even even material gifts
and we we need to remember that that
purpose is beyond us and to use those
gifts responsibly for that broader
purpose
that's beautiful uh the next statement
comes from the namesake of the
institution of which I am the associate
director Arthur C Clarke Center for
human imagination here and Arthur C
Clarke famously said any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
for magic you're a very eminent
scientist thinking scientifically
imagine you make a monolith like that in
2001 A Space Odyssey the movies and you
could put anything on it that summarizes
the greatest discovery not made by you
although it could be uh but but the
greatest scientific fact imaginable to
kind of have a little bit of braggadocio
about what human beings are capable of
what's the most astonishing thing in
your field in any field about our
scientific universe
[Music]
I mean in my field we can heal people
with the worst diseases that were before
we never imagined we could do you have
cancer there's so many cancers we can
treat now
cure you have you have uh all these
conditions that have plagued Humanity
for generations for for Millennia
um and we can fix it
um we just have to we have to remember
that even when we're doing that we still
can't
stop you from dying altogether I mean
it's it's amazing what we can do we live
so much longer than we once did because
of science
um but at the same time you have to stay
humble we still haven't conquered death
we probably never will absolutely uh the
next question is another quote uh from
Sir Arthur C Clarke uh he said the
following wanna distinguished but
elderly scientist says something is
possible they are almost certainly right
but when they say something is
impossible they are very probably wrong
I'm not calling you elderly you're not
the gray hair going on I use a Sharpie
so it keeps me uh not being as
distinguished as you um what have you
changed your mind about what if anything
have you felt I was wrong about uh in
your in your scientific work
[Music]
I think I'm just just run covid there's
been a lot of things probably the most
consequential thing I got wrong was that
in March of 2020 I thought there was no
way to get a vaccine in a year no chance
um because normally my understanding was
it would take a decade to find a good
the right target for the vaccine and
then quite a long time to test it a year
or more to test test the vaccine yeah
the fact that we could get the political
and oil and the scientific capacity to
produce a vaccine so rapidly blew my
mind I'm still amazed by it
um and so I I kind of was pleased to be
wrong about that I do I do regret how
the vaccine was used I think it could
have been used to for Focus protection
of older people I'm very strongly in
favor of that
um but it also was used to divide the
population to to to to to create shame
for people who just who had some
reservations about taking for whatever
reason and essentially to like uh
discriminate against people and that I
think was is Regret to be regretted but
that was the social use of actually not
the amazing technical achievement of
getting the vaccine in such a short time
right and then the last law of Arthur C
Clarke States the following the only way
of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them into the impossible and that's the
original name of my podcast and I asked
this in the phrase a form of advice to
your former self what mysterious aspect
of life maybe perplexed you as a 20 year
old or 30 year old but later in moments
of great clarity through inciting
incidents or breakthroughs LED you to
become the person that you are a person
of great courage as well as great
intellect in other words what would you
tell that 30 year old 20 year old Jay to
give him the courage to do as you've
done to go into the impossible
foreign
it's really easy for young people and
certainly that was true for me to think
that uh everyone else around you
especially the older people who have
distinguished careers know everything
and that they that they can tell you you
know you you're on to something or not
onto something I tell that 20 year old a
30 year old that's doing science you
know no one really has all the answers
it's not and and if they're telling you
no it's not because they know no they
just they just you know that's the
knee-jerk reaction almost everything is
wrong uh you need to have some
confidence in yourself you might be
right and all of all the old guys around
you with gray hair might be wrong that's
certainly possible it's almost that's
how science advances Brian uh is when
but gray hairs like me get proven wrong
um and I think that's a really good
thing yeah well uh Dr J balachari uh
Professor Stanford School of Medicine MD
PhD uh Health policy expert uh so much
more uh this has been such a treat for
me at Jay I'm gonna have links to your
to your Twitter uh profile where you can
follow Jay at Dr J letter j balacharya
and uh and follow him and and tune in
and I do hope you'll share I mean this
audience is you know gonna gonna expand
your profile you know just so
exponentially this appearance to you you
won't be able to handle it uh but uh but
you won't lose any weight maybe you'll
gain some weight from this exposure but
I do hope you'll share it in the form of
a memoir because it's such a remarkable
story of Courage under extreme I mean
basically the worst situation an
academic could find him herself in that
you've weathered hopefully for good and
I wish you uh blessings and and peace I
think that's uh nothing good can come
without the blessings of health and
peace so Jay thank you so much for being
on the podcast thank you Brian I'm so
honored to know you as a friend thank
you for the podcast it's a blessing for
me my friend take care take care
foreign
[Music]